mesdames et messieurs bonsoir notre
invité ici en direct le grand rabbin
kaplan après l'attentât indignation
c'est un mot qu'on emploiera souvent ce
soir plusieurs manifestations en
province et à paris
a paris il y en a eu trois millions
d'abord celle qui se déroule en ce
moment même place de l'opéra organisé
par le cnes le comité de liaison des
étudiants sioniste et socialistes sur
place françois cornes
oui il ya déjà plusieurs milliers de
personnes rassemblées ici place de
l'opéra et des slogans anti fascistes
vous vous en doutez alors on ne sait pas
très bien ce que va faire le cnes le
cnes vous le savez c'est l'ultra des
mouvements juive
ils ne sont pas toujours du même avis
que le mrap ou la licra eux prônent
l'autodéfense et le retour en israël des
juifs de france alors que vont ils faire
après ce rassemblement place de l'opéra
vers quelle direction vont ils se
dirigeaient on ne sait pas très bien
pour l'instant je vous le dis plusieurs
milliers de personnes ici et ce qui
inquiète un peu les services de police
que nous avons eu tout à l'heure ce sont
les les gens qui n'ont rien à voir avec
cette manifestation et qui pourtant se
rassemblent ici en ce moment avec le
cnes place de l'opéra ce matin à
l'office religieux du samedi qui s'est
tenue dans la synagogue de la rue
copernic il y avait beaucoup de monde et
pas seulement des français de confession
israélite bien d'autres personnes
étaient venues manifester par leur
présence leur sympathie à la communauté
juive de nice breil
c'est environ un millier de personnes
qui sont venues là ce matin à 10 heures
assister à l'office du shabbat qui était
célébrée par le rabbin williams à la
synagogue de la rue copernic
ceux qui n'avaient pu entrer sont restés
dans la rue une foule grave et émue dans
une rue bouclée à chaque extrémité par
une dizaine de policiers
l'office commencé en présence de
plusieurs personnalités
au moment de la prière des morts simone
veil n'a pu cacher son émotion
par la force des produits répondant à
l'appel du renouveau juif
tous les participants ont rejoint la
manifestation stylisé la force première
à d'abord itv ce prix ils étaient
plusieurs milliers qui ont descendu les
champs elysées en direction du ministère
de l'intérieur
un service d'ordre efficace tentaient de
contenir la nervosité de certains des
jeunes ayant pris à partie dès le départ
du cortège des membres des
renseignements généraux est un touriste
étranger
les abords du ministère de l'intérieur
ayant été interdit par la police les
manifestants se regroupaient carré
marigny
là le grand rabbin shear a theory à jen
berg président du renouveau juif lancé
un appel au calme et demandé la
démission de christian bonnet l'ordre de
dispersion était donné quelques dizaines
de jeunes repoussé par le service
d'ordre du renouveau juif bousculait
madame veil qui n'a pu se dégager qu'au
bout d'un quart d'heure grâce à
l'intervention de la police
à 14h30 environ 5000 manifestants
répondaient à l'appel du mrap
cet après midi le ministre de
l'intérieur devait recevoir une
délégation du mrap cependant que la
manifestation se disperse est à 16
heures pour en venir et hier soir
comment l'explosion s'était produite il
ya toujours deux hypothèses ou bien
l'engin d'une dizaine de kilos donc très
puissant a été placée sur le toit de la
mairie arrêté près laetitia gogh ou
plutôt c'est l'hypothèse la plus
vraisemblable dans la sacoche d'un
vélomoteur ou sur la selle de celui ci
le ministre de l'intérieur a mis trois
compagnies de crs supplémentaires à la
disposition du préfet de police pour
protéger les biens sacré de la
communauté juive ce qui porte à 5 depuis
le début de la présente semaine le
nombre de ces compagnies spéciale de crs
dans d'autres villes notamment à
strasbourg et à nancy
les mesures exceptionnelles ont été
prises dans le même sens par ailleurs
les policiers ont interpellé tôt ce
matin dans la capitale et en banlieue 13
membres des milieux extrémistes de
droite qui ont été placés en garde à vue
je rappelle que dès hier soir et
aussitôt que l'attentât était connue le
président de la république avait demandé
au ministre de l'intérieur et à la
police une action exemplaire pour
retrouver et les coupables et il l'a
écrit joe bar ou du président au grand
rabbin jeu d'andré lecture de la lettre
tout à l'heure en interviewant notre
invité l'attentât a soulevé
l'indignation partout dans toutes les
formations politiques professionnelles
et syndicales de l'extrême droite
classique jusqu'à l'extrême gauche il ya
unanimité sur ce point la presse est
elle aussi unanime à condamner ce qui
s'est passé une revue de la presse
présenté par jean-michel mercure
la transe tuerie de la rue copernic et
est l'oeuvre d'une internationale noir
s'interrogent le monde en tout cas
l'horreur était prévisible si l'on en
croit jacques fauvet pour qui la lutte
contre le terrorisme
si elle n'a jamais été une tâche facile
n'aurait pas dû se contenter de
combattre l'extrémisme de gauche au
point de négliger l'extrémisme de droite
pour la croix voilà le plus monstrueux
attentats antisémites depuis la guerre
pourquoi la police est elle impuissante
à endiguer le réveil du fascisme
poursuit l'éditorial n'est ce pas du
fait que notre société tout entière se
laisse peu à peu contaminés par la haine
raciale se demande encore la croix
assassin's écrit le quotidien de paris
assassin répond l'humanité l'horreur
dénonce le figaro monstrueux clame
france soir la condamnation est unanime
dans la presse ce matin qu'il s'agisse
encore du parisien halte aux assassins
ou de libération nous sommes tous des
juifs français
cette haine raciste qui a provoqué
l'odieux attentat antisémite comme le
dit le matin cette haine antisémite et
est dénoncée déjà par ce titre
prémonitoire des nouvelles littéraires
cette semaine ac a fait après bologne
munich paris le drame était dans l'air à
tel point que trois autres hebdomadaires
avaient fait de la violence le thème de
leur couverture avant même l'attentât de
paris violence peur racisme pour
l'express racisme antisémitisme
terrorisme pour le nouvel observateur la
peste brune enfin pour témoignage
chrétien
il est vrai que l'attentât de munich
évoquées par paris match par le figaro
magazine et par vsd
on avait malheureusement déjà fourni la
matière
le point qui en dernière minute a pu
insérer la nouvelle de l'attentât parle
du terrorisme noir d'une extrême droite
néo nazi qu'il importe désormais de
prendre au sérieux le pape jean paul ii
a condamné avec indignation l'atteinte à
dans un télégramme au cardinal marty il
s'associe aux prières pour des victimes
innocentes et formule des voeux ardents
pour que de telles violences soient
définitivement bannis
parce qu'un digne de l'homme et à plus
forte raison d'un chrétien
monsieur le grand rabbin hier à cause de
la juive c'était le début du sabbat
vous n'avez pas pu paraître en personne
à la télévision aujourd'hui vous pouvez
dire les réflexions que vous inspire
l'acte affreux d'hier je peux vous dire
que cette 1ere un événement infiniment
douloureux j'en suis profondément
attristé attristé pour ma communauté
attristé également pour le pays
ainsi on en est venu là en france en
1981 un cif des fidèles réunis dans une
synagogue
hommes femmes enfants
tout à leur prière un jour du sabbat le
sabar qui chez nous le symbole de la
sérénité un sur deux tout à leurs
prières et on en est pris à du sabbat
nous faisons les prières pour la france
et nous faisons des prières pour la paix
et voici que brusquement l'attentât
monstrueux ce produit attentats
monstrueux qui fait penser à d'autres
attentats monstrueux à celui de wohlen à
celui de munnich et on peut on frémit à
l'idée que si la bombe avait éclaté un
peu plus tard on aurait vu un véritable
massacre
et pourtant les spectacles qu'on a vu
hier elle était un spectacle
particulièrement émouvant ina francs
dont ces circonstances je dois dire que
nous avons trouvé un congrès confère un
grand réconfort de la part de de
l'ensemble de la queue de l'heure dans
l'ensemble du pays
nous avons reçu les témoignages de tous
les côtés où je n'avais publié un
certain nombre ou même vous avez fait
connaître est entre autres puis un autre
que j'ai rushé ricco avait reçu vous
même
oui salut l'origine à celui du président
alors je veux et lecture aux
téléspectateurs le président de la
république et crée donc au grand rabbin
kaplan
parlant au nom du peuple français je
vous exprime mon émotion et mon
indignation devant le dieu attentats en
ce moment de douleur je vous redis
l'estimé d'amitié personnelle que je
porte à la communauté juive de france
j'ai donné des directions express afin
que tous soient mises en a
pour retrouver traduire devant la
justice les auteurs de cette action
criminelle sachez que dans une
semblables circonstances de sentiments
qui réunit les français de toutes
origines et de toutes confessions et
celui de leur étroite solidarité et le
chef de l'état mais le grand rabbin vous
demande de croire à sa sympathie
personnelle pour vous même et pour la
communauté juive nous en viendrons tout
à l'heure à bologne et à munich pour le
moment de l copains à d'autres questions
monsieur michel rabat le président de la
république et annonce qu'il a donné des
directives express d'une façon générale
dette vous rassurés par les déclarations
qui ont été faites par les dirigeants du
pays et aussi par l'ensemble de leurs
des mouvements politiques les mouvements
syndicaux et autres et pour que vous
sachiez qu'à côté du du pression de
république il y a eu des témoignages qui
était monté été adressée directement à
l'intention de la communauté par des
membres du gouvernement par des nombreux
parlementaires par des représentants de
tous les partis par des représentants
les plus élevés de la religion
catholique de la religion protestante et
de la religion orthodoxe est également
d'aider des syndicats ils ont parlé les
particuliers qui m'ont envoyé leurs
témoignages il ya donc des témoignages
de solidarité très très large mais en
dehors de ces événements et ce qui
n'arrive pas quand même à notre époque
que la communauté juive de france se
sentent un peu isolé dans ce pays
je n'ai pas du tout le sentiment à aucun
moment j'ai eu le sentiment que la
communauté se trouve isolé lorsqu'il n'y
ait eu dernièrement des manifestations
d'antisémitisme
nous avons eu également des réactions
alizés pas aussi loue aussi nombreux et
aussi parce que maintenant puisqu'il
s'agit là d'une véritable tragédie mais
les manifestations de sympathie da
d'ignacio ne nous ont pas voté
cette tragédie est elle le signe tous
les autres attentats dont vous avez que
vous avez rappelé à l'instant elles sont
ils le signe d'une remontée de
l'antisémitisme en france depuis
quelques années c'est certain que c'est
certain la seule particularité
actuellement c'est parce que cet
antisémitisme
se présentait découvert aussitôt après
la libération
les antisémites qui était resté
antisémites nous est pas se manifester
en tant qu antisémites et c'était une
aubaine pour eux deux que la création
d'un état d'israël et l'antisionisme il
se camoufler derrière l'antisionisme et
voilà qu'avec le temps qui a passé il ya
maintenant près de 40 ans eh bien il ose
se présenter à visage découvert
mélenchon selliti se se poursuivaient ta
moufles et pendant très longtemps et
maintenant il se montre sans aucune
crainte avec une audace a eu mal fait
sens quelque chose qui est inouï
monsieur le grand rabbin vous voyez tout
à l'heure regarder avec une particulière
attention sur notre écran ces jeunes qui
défilait en protestant contre l'acte
criminel d'hier que ressentez-vous en
voyant toute cette jeunesse qui
protestent cela comprend très bien mais
on je partage moi même je partage moi
même leur colère et leur indignation
mais malgré tout je crois va le devoir
de leur dire de ne pas tomber dans le
piège qui leur est tendu par des
antisémites
c'est à dire dans le piège de la
violence
vous avez entendu lundi la lettre du
président de l'écurie des jeux la montre
avec roy ou si oui où il est dit entre
parle en particulier
j'ai donné des directives express
directive express eh bien je dis à tous
nos jeunes pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé que je sais ferme que je sais
résolu jordi malgré tout 2 d'attendre le
résultat de ces directives express et
d'attendre également les directives qui
pourrait leur être données par le
conseil représentatif des flux de france
et encore une fois je renouvelle mon
appel à nos jeunes en leur disant de ne
pas tomber dans ce piège parce que sans
le vouloir ils feront le jeu des
antisémites mais selon en vain
qu'attendez vous des autres grandes
religions français pratiqué en france
je n'ai rien tant de particuliers nous
ont témoigné leur solidarité et je sais
que acte que depuis depuis vatican ii et
même avant l'antisémitisme chrétien et
est refusé par la hiérarchie et par
quantité d'organisations chrétiennes
il n'y a plus d' antisémitisme chrétiens
donc c'est pas de nous sommes sûrs de
l'amitié des représentants les
les plus élevées des 10 des diverses
religions je regarde un merci pour votre
présence en direct sur notre plateau
le bureau exécutif du parti socialiste
vient de se réunir à paris sous la
présidence de monsieur mitterrand
la réunion a commencé il y à une demi
heure
nous pouvons d'ores et déjà vous donner
un extrait de ce qu'a dit le premier
secrétaire du ps
le gouès par ma présence à la synagogue
rue copernic
j'ai clairement montré que c'était mes
sentiments et ma solidarité
et au besoin par j ai décrit comme vous
le savez que j'ai tel ami et le parti
fasciste aussi de la communauté juive vu
que cette communauté comme c'est des
jours de malheur et bien au delà d'elle
la france et les français
il était normal que nous fussions auprès
d'elle tous les autres commentaires sont
un ordre qui était faisait par la
structure exécutif et dans les termes
vous êtes vous être maintenant que lyon
vous êtes aussi critique le bureau
exécutif du ps réunie aujourd'hui a
demandé la démission du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur bonnet à la suite
de l'attentât d'hier il a par ailleurs
adressé une lettre aux deux présidents
des assemblées pour que le gouvernement
s'explique dès lundi devant les
parlementaires
selon monsieur bûche secrétaire général
de la fédération autonome des syndicats
de police un cinquième des militants de
la femme l'ex fédération d'action
nationaliste européennes seraient des
policiers à l'issue d'une conférence de
presse il l'a répété à dominique l'offre
nous sommes aujourd'hui le sert et
devoirs et d'enregistrer que dans les
nids-de-poule que dans le vent la police
nationale puisse se trouver des gens qui
se réclament d'un réseau par exemple
honneur de la police qui revendique
l'assassinât de pierre goldman par
exemple le plasticage d'un militant
cégétiste
et ça je suis persuadé qu'au plus haut
niveau dans les directions et dans la
police judiciaire on n'ignore pas le nom
de ces gens qui appartiennent à ce
réseau si toutefois il existe et s'il
existe moi je vous dis que c'est la
honte de la police nationale que des
gens puissent servir dans ses rangs vous
avez des preuves comme quoi des éléments
en néo nazis sont infiltrés dans la
police bon allez savoir nous avons une
preuve vous avez eu l'inspecteur durant
il est bien certain que si on avait pu
mener le combat que nous avons mené
durant il serait encore et que d'autres
durant continué d'y être il y en a
d'autres et nous sommes persuadés qu'il
y en a d'autres d'ailleurs je crois que
mon camarade thorn qui est le secrétaire
général du sm apc ne sais pas du tout
avancé la légère lorsqu'il dit que dans
les militants de la fan il y en a au
moins un policier sur 5 ou le monde le
sait donc on se demande pourquoi qu'on
niveau le plus on ne prend pas des
dispositions pour épurer la police
nationale mais alors que réclamez-vous
exactement des antennes des arrestations
préventives a tout simplement nous
désirons nous voulons nous exigeons
qu'il y ait une commission enquête
parlementaire qu'il puisse enfin essayer
de faire la lumière dans tout ce qui se
passe aussi ce trafic dans la brise
des accusations très graves que
maintenant mais des accusations très
graves nous le savons mais nous les
avons dit au ministre de l'intérieur
lui-même
pourquoi on vous le répéterai pas vous
on espère que cette fois au moins pour
une fois dehors à l'audience de
l'opinion publique
alors monsieur christian benêt ministre
de l'intérieur vient d'annoncer qu'il
allait demander la dissolution de tous
les mouvements d'extrême droite
quels sont ils et qui sont-ils paul
lefebvre vient d'avoir la fan le siège
de l'ex fans semble être maintenant
inoccupé depuis le 3 septembre dernier
date de la dissolution du mouvement par
les miss de l'intérieur mais le 23 du
mois nous pourrions aussi recouvert
d'affichés d'ailleurs du betar une
organisation de jeunes sionistes groupe
emma de temps semble-t-il dans l'eau jd
l'organisation geste défense et bien ce
23 est également le siège du centre de
culture européenne et des fessiers
nationalistes européens qui sont les
deux organisations qui ont succédé à la
fan alors je suppose que monsieur marc
frederix haine qui est le leader de ces
deux mouvements réunissent autres par
ses militants chaque grande tendance de
l'extrême droite française a donc donné
naissance à des groupes plus ou moins
activis plus ou moins marginaux des
groupes qui se fondent et qui change de
dénomination en fonction de leurs
actions groupe delta groupe charles
martel honneur de la police belge on
parlait alors des éléments également
plus structuré les gènes herbes et les
groupes nationaux révolutionnaire de
base formé d'un certain nombre de
militants du front national
l'union solidariste à 10 mai par jean
pierre stirbois les groupes
d'intervention nationaliste une fraction
marginale du mouvement nationaliste
révolutionnaire de jean gilles
malliarakis et cetera
alors la femme semblait être le
rassemblement des éléments les plus durs
en tout cas ceux qui ont basculé tout de
suite dans la violence le nombre de
leurs militants n'est pas très important
pas très connus ou non valu à peu près
un millier en france
il met en tout cas ils sont tous très
jeunes motivés et on a décompté 227
attentats de leur part depuis juin 1977
alors à ce propos je voudrais redire ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure en
commençant le journal
c'est que trois compagnies de crs
supplémentaires avaient été mis à la
disposition du préfet de police de paris
mme somme veille par le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur bonnet pour
protéger les biens sacré de la
communauté juive et
des mesures mais même sens entreprises
dans d'autres villes strasbourg nancy et
d'autres jeux revient alors à l'étranger
ces mouvements dont vous parlez il en
existe de semblable aguets et on appelle
ça l'international noir plus précisément
ces îles sont regroupés au jour des
contacts dans ce qu'on appelle l'union
mondiale national socialiste qui a été
créée en 1966 par les américains et les
anglais alors au trou de ce genre de
mouvement en belgique au portugal en
espagne en amérique du sud aux états
unis en angleterre en italie en
allemagne
ils se rencontrent tous les deux ans les
dernières réunions il ya une réunion
dans les pyrénées du côté espagnol entre
79 et il semble que cette année deux
réunions et eu lieu une à madrid et à
nice c'est mouvement d'extrême droite
ont subi ce toons le même phénomène ils
sont laminés au niveau de l'opinion
publique au niveau au plan parlementaire
car il ne représente pas grand chose au
niveau parlementaire dont il s'exprime
dans la rue et la violence c'est un
phénomène qu'on retrouve en italie et en
allemagne en particulier dit oui en
quelques semaines trois graves à pantin
en europe la gare de bologne en italie
un autre à la fête de la bière à munich
hier et la synagogue de la rue copernic
il paraît quasi certain qu'il ya un lien
entre les trois actions criminelles à
leurs questions existe-t-il un neuro
nazisme d'abord de munich
michel meyer il y a eu des contacts très
précis et très suivi entre des néonazis
français des néonazis allemands
notamment dans le cadre de ce fameux
groupe hoffman mis en relation avec le
dernier attentat de munich
à cet égard précisément le groupe
kaufman servait de cadre pour des
entraînements paramilitaires où l'on
retrouvait dans des camps de bavière
destiné à cet effet des français des
belges des italiens et des allemands
on peut noter entre parenthèses que ce
sont certains néo nazis français qui
finançait partiellement ce fameux groupe
hoffman ciment idéologique de tous ces
activistes la nostalgie d'une sorte
d'ordre à la hitler la haine également
pour tout ce qui est rouge d'opinion
brin de pau et juifs de religion cadre
national de ces fascistes à linverse de
l'allemagne nazie et bien l'europe et
non pas l'allemagne strictement en tant
que nation peut-on parler d'une
internationale noir de la terreur
voici que serait l'opinion des services
italiens de renseignements il y a des
rapports constants entre les
organisations néo fasciste ou néo nazis
en europe mais en ce qui concerne
l'action directe et en particulier les
attentats chaque organisation agi en
fonction des conditions locales par
exemple un attentat du genre de celui de
la rue de copernic à paris n'aurait pas
de sens en italie il y aurait donc entre
ces organisations un but commun une
entraide
mais il n'y aurait pas de stratégie
comme une bonne raison très simple c'est
que ces organisations ne sont pas assez
puissantes pour avoir une stratégie
commune en europe
quelles premières conclusions peut-on
tirer aujourd'hui de cet ensemble
d'informations après la tragédie d'hier
nous l'avons demandé à raymond aron
philosophe de l'histoire un homme qui
peut prendre du recul car il appartient
à une génération d'avant guerre paul
amar lui a posé d'abord la question de
savoir si un demi siècle après l'époque
de la peste brune et de la haine raciste
triomphante l'histoire pouvait se
répéter l'histoire ne se répète pas
l'antisémitisme est un phénomène qui
dure depuis des millénaires
en tout cas depuis mille années il n'y a
aucune raison que l'antisémitisme
disparaissent de manière miraculeuse du
jour au lendemain par de sud manche et
en dépit de cet attentat en dépit de
notre émotion
il faut prendre conscience du fait que
la situation actuelle reste
fondamentalement différente de celle des
années
quand il n'y a pas un grand mouvement
anti sémite il y à des groupuscules
d'assassins c'est pas la même chose tout
de même monsieur à rentrer dans un
entretien accordé récemment au monde
vous sembliez relativement optimiste cet
optimisme est contredit non je disais
dans cet entretien qu'il y avait des
groupuscules qui était capable d'aller
jusqu'au bout mais qu'il n'y avait pas
de parti antisémite et que dans
l'ensemble de la france
l'antisémitisme était disparu des
phénomènes acceptable or je crois au
encore aujourd'hui que pour l'essentiel
c'est vrai avec cette réserve que je
faisais moi-même dans cette interview du
fait de ma situation du fait de mon âge
du fait des sommes que je fréquente je
puis ignoré certains aspects de
l'antisémitisme qui existe dans la
france mais ce que nous observons depuis
quelques semaines c'est l' escalade de
la violence de ces groupuscules
cela ne signifie pas qu'il n'ya aucun
parti français qui soit consciemment ou
inconsciemment en 18
ne croyez vous tout de même pas que ces
actes puissent être favorisée par
certains intellectuels qui d'une manière
déguisée ou non prendre des théories pas
seulement ici mais raciste est
généralement et goûter vous montez rejet
ou bien dans l'abstrait ou bien sûr des
esgaulx riches
je me refuse à l' amalgame entre les
exercices intellectuels de telle ou
telle personne
avec ces assassinats aussi longtemps
qu'il y a une liberté de pensée et
d'écriture il est inévitable qu'un
certain nombre d'intellectuels exprime
des idées qui me font horreur mais aussi
longtemps que cette liberté existera ne
pouvons pas l'empêcher et aussi
longtemps que ceux auxquels vous songé
une exprimeront de manière directe
aucune opinion d' antisémitisme ne
pousseront d'aucune manière aux
attentats nous n'avons pas le droit de
les accuser aujourd'hui un autre jour
nous discuterons de nouveau avec eux
c'est juste monsieur arômes éléments
peuvent être dangereux tous les mots
sont dangereux les mots tus je le sais
nous le savons tous nous l'avons écrit
mais la liberté de la pensée aussi est
dangereuse et je ne pense pas que vous
vouliez la supprimer
non les démocraties comment
peuvent-elles réagir et résister elles
doivent d'abord résisté par la pensée
par la parole par la discussion est
ensuite lorsqu'on est en phase de
groupuscules il n'ya qu'une réponse une
défense c'est la police or le fait est
que les groupes extrémistes de gauche
ont été dans une large mesure
démantelées par la police
il reste à la police de démontrer
qu'elle est la police tenait à
républicain et de démanteler ces
groupuscules d'extrême droite
j'espère qu'elle le froid jusqu'à
présent je me refuse à m'associer au
déni espérons dénonciation globale de
l'état français responsable des
assassinats d'hier et il y a peut être
eu de la faiblesse de la part de l'un ou
de l'autre mais je connais le ministre
de l'intérieur je sais que sa bonne
volonté et entière même s'il est
éventuellement sous-estimer l'importance
du phénomène et demain monsieur avant
que va-t-il se passer que peut-il se
passer tout à partir du moment où un
groupe de fous essaye de déstabiliser la
france et donner une réalité à leurs
délires les répliques les réponses
peuvent être à leur tour folle et la
seule chose que l'on peut dire quand on
est français
quand on est français de confession
juive c'est de supplier tous les autres
qui ont conservé la raison de ne pas la
perdre
françois corps mais nous appelle de la
place de l'opéra où se déroule la
manifestation du crès avoue indirects
transports oui on peut déjà tirer une
première conclusion ce soir les autres
mouvements juifs ne se sont pas mêlés
aux classes vous le savez je vous le dis
tout à l'heure le cnes est réputé
difficile ultra il est pour le retour en
israël des juifs de france il prône
l'autodéfense alors on peut dire que ce
soir ils sont nombreux mais ils se
trouvent un peu seul sur cette place de
l'opéra le cortège comme vous le voyez
commencent à quitter la place de l'opéra
il se dirige maintenant vers la rue
copernic
nous aurons vraisemblablement d'autres
images à vous présenter dans notre
édition de 23h à vous les 11 itron il y
à risque d'extension du conflit raynaud
irakien le roi hussein pourrait annoncer
bagdad où il se trouve aujourd'hui la
participation des forces jordaniennes au
co2 les forces irakiennes c'est ce que
nous dit lou dépêchait fait en
provenance de jordanie
en pologne le numéro un du parti
communiste kahniens annoncé à la suite
d'un nouveau plénum du comité central
une réforme prochaine profonde du
système de gestion et de direction il
estime nécessaire de procéder à des
changements dans le fonctionnement des
instances politiques et ce dans la
perspective dit il d'un renouveau moral
il fait en vo qu'un congrès
extraordinaire du parti comme gage de la
réalisation des objectifs en belgique
démission de monsieur martens la
collision au la part dont la coalition
qu'il présidait cette envie ce look est
à propos du programme économique du
gouvernement
dans un mois les états unis choisissent
leur président comme tous les quatre ans
à cette occasion antenne 2 fera un
effort exceptionnel et dès après demain
nous envoyés spéciaux vous montrerons ce
que sont les états unis d'aujourd'hui
vous retrouverez dès lundi en direct des
etats unis les journaux présenté hors
antenne 2010 par daniel bilalian
et le soir à 20h par patrick poivre
d'arvor et puis lundi soir après le
journal à 20h35 question tant sur la vie
actuelle aux états unis présentée par
jean-pierre elkabbach nous changeons
complètement de registre de mao course
la plus grande journée de l'année
pierrette brès le prix de l'arc de
triomphe le championnat du monde des
pur-sang et avant cela il faut préciser
que contrairement à d'autres grandes
épreuves classiques
le prix de l'arc de triomphe réunit
toujours beaucoup de partants demain ils
seront 21 a essayé de s'attribuer les 1
million 500 mille francs offerts aux
vainqueurs et parmi ces 21 chevaux
juments j'ai deux trois ans a
quelquefois plus il ne pas que des
cracks bien sûr
alors c'est une course qui est
extrêmement facile a pronostiqué
car logiquement l'arrivée se devait se
disputer entre 5 6 chevaux alors tout de
suite je vous propose d'en sort plus sur
ses favoris quinze jours pour le prix de
l'arc de triomphe pour ce sont proposés
aux concurrents pour parfaire leur
préparation
il s'agit d'épreuves classique qui se
court à longchamp je vous propose de
revoir les arrivées du prix nièce du
prix foy et du prix prince d'orange dans
lesquelles nous retrouverons quelques
favoris de l'arc de triomphe
tout d'abord policeman le gagnant du
vieux club que vous voyez actuellement
queue de peloton dans le prix niel
police même casaque rouge manches vertes
et au cou noir et rouge fait toujours
ses courses en avant et ce jour là il
fait une course d'attenté
pourquoi j'ai donné des ordres à saint
martin qui se met le couvert derrière
qui viennent sur les autres parce que
j'avais peur que après le la cour fasse
un clou et l'a vu une course assez dur
en avant en avant que ça serait
peut-être ça lui ferait du bien
et malheureusement les cheval s'est
collé contre noté puis ne voulais pas
partir il a débuté à cagnes mal et l'est
resté dans les boîtes puis il a gagné il
est troisième il a gagné encore
et après il est venu à paris et il a
bluffé tout le monde n'en jetez club
parce que personne chez moi qui s'est
trompé de distance que je pensais que
c'était un cheval de 10 800 m 2 mm et en
fin de compte c'est seulement parce que
c'est une clé a insisté qui courent le
jockey club
dans le prix foy le marmot qui est au
centre casaque bleu et noir top noir
semble peiner pour défendre la risée
mais un petit détail de poids son jockey
n'utilise pas la cravache le marmot
gagne tout de même certains prétendent
qu'il n'a pas bien gagner moi je crois
qu'il va très bien gagner parce que je
connais je le connais bien c'est un
cheval à ses jets en prenant de l'âge je
suis venu un petit peu rouillé s'en fait
pas trop et messi mais je me suffit de
voir les 100 derniers mètres comme il
s'est allongé un peu il va courir en
très gros progrès la coi à mon avis 8 à
10 kg supérieure dans le présent le
crime comment l'avez-vous être que c'est
sale et combien les rivaux ici j'ai
acheté au vent d'ovelia devant je prends
oui devant et de formules francs c'est
combien vaut-il actuellement comme
monnaie internationale autour de 4
millions de dollars près ce qui fait à
peu près sur un porte monnaie anciennes
1 milliard 600 médias ont peu près
enchères c'est une belle réussite pour
vous et produits finale dans le tri
presse d'orange du net à la corde
al'avantage friterie casque sac beige
manche et toque noire à l'extérieur
luttent courageusement et cette deuxième
place nous rassure car cela prouve tout
de même que la figure qu'elle s'était
faite à un pied est tout à fait guéri
d'une est la gagnante aura encore toutes
ses chances dans l'arc de triomphe alors
on dirait vous avez retrouvé votre
dînette ne pouvais pas courir dimanche
dernier parce qu'elle était malade elle
a eu des coliques dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche
elle a eu très mal au ventre et on a été
obligé de faire des piqûres pour la
calmer
j'ai eu très peur parce qu'il ya des
chevaux qui en meurent enfin maintenant
ça va ça vient
alors j'ai confiance pour l'arc pour le
design en bas du mois est bien le titre
eca s'est battu par du net mais après
une lutte farouche
qu'est ce que vous pensez que le monstre
est satisfait de sa course pense qu'elle
a bien court
sa ville a été arrêté très longtemps
elle a besoin de ça et je pense qu'elle
est bien plus qu on fait ça en fait
j'écris mon gars l'objectif c'était la
région c'est la dunette vous a déjà
battu c'est pas d honneur d'être battu
par dix neuf et bien ça sent le marmot
mon favori parce qu'il a une revanche à
prendre les dernières il était deuxième
du prix de l'arc de triomphe derrière
lui je passe à three troïkas qui elle a
gagné lac est là elle défendra chèrement
son titre et puis ensuite du net
lynette doit normalement faire partie
des trois premiers dans cette course et
la mana mousser le grand champion
anglais il aura contre lui de n'avoir
jamais couru à longchamp
en revanche sa compatriote missy ceni
elle vient de gagner à longchamp et elle
sera très dangereuse dans cette course
et puis il ya policeman qui vient de
gagner le cac gagné le prix du jockey
club
on ne peut pas l'éliminer détroit qui
est considéré comme la meilleure de sa
génération et pour terminer aryenne qui
est des performances est très
irrégulière mais il saint-martin choisi
de monter ça peut être une indication je
pense en de gamme nous vous
transmettrons le prix de l'arc de
triomphe demain en direct à partir de
16h15 la météo demain ça intéresse les
participants après la dissipation des
brumes matinales le ciel sera ensoleillé
cependant des nuages plus abondants
seront observées dans le nord-est et
près des pyrénées ou des ondées
orageuses sont possibles notre édition
est terminée ce soir gérard holtz vous
présentera des dernières informations
demain si tel est votre choix nous nous
retrouverons antennes de midi et pour le
journal de 20h
bonne soirée merci